walk him to this video playing Prince
hmm ok Peter of yet good I don't know
this guy John player okay let's see what
we get probably something like
something's is large like play this
without deform interesting yeah d for
transposes to the chobani ankles laughs
but I'm trying to do without it getting
somewhat different positions mmm g6
interesting don't really know don't
really know this too well with Bishop f5
is Bishop f5 is interesting I always
have queen bee three though yeah it's
not quite clear what what am I doing
here
hmm yeah I don't know maybe I can just
play these three if he goes Bishop f5
not that this leads to much but g6 is
interesting maybe maybe Quincy to is
just to only a nap should play be three
or something I mean what I tried to say
is that here there are ideas without
default but I simply didn't play it in a
way that it sets black any problems yeah
yeah my day 6 sentence and things like
that but I'm trying to play for reform I
couldn't just do so immediately because
of the long diagonal yeah not much
choice 95 though oh I have have 94 at
least and maybe maybe I can even take
are taking okay but I can play Knight
deform if everything else fails if it
takes and place 95 may you are still 94
at least this keeps some material Wow
completely unexpected move okay well I
wanted to do that anyway so why not now
but they have before coming
yeah before here yeah I guess so it's a
I guess helpful to keep the night from
c5 it starts to look like a relatively
normal position again okay interesting
move so b5 night before that's not too
great so do i need to take yeah maybe
maybe i do so at least i have a decent
development the rukon be one is
supposing the queen
and not quite sure what you should do
now ray Knight 96 to a for something
like that I have 95 coming aha
interesting Bishop takes yeah Bishop c5
is also move okay but keep it simple
yeah I thought rook b5 might be might be
something getting him into a pin okay
let's do that
so might be 95 okay I need to be cooking
I could have taken but okay three all
kinds of stuff I don't know 95 looks
like it looks like a good move as well
no is simply ignoring all of it ok check
okay so is he will go back to e5 i
guess--i 7s hanging mmm yeah Bishop f4
Queenie six must be played it's not look
great but I don't have a brilliant light
move I have rook takes be six actually
ok so I'm Bishop f4 is good ok I
probably win a pawn then
okay so I'll take be six anyway if I go
Rupe do you want to ask the Queen going
don't see a square actually it's just
trapped yeah I don't have a Hitler it
doesn't have a square I mean you said
Sheamus check but the queen is simply
trapped a bit of a strange game I mean
this is certainly cannot be a be great
for white maybe a about about equal but
here I mean after your father's looks
like why does is comfortable and this
should be should be good for some some
advantage at least I have no space all
of a sudden and this is nicely opposing
yeah it here oops sorry okay here i'm
just-just nicely developed ya hear the
computer once plane 95 with the big
action ok but this also seems to keep an
advantage yeah yeah yes he has some
coordination issues if you look at this
for example I'll take yang winning a
piece and so yeah this check yeah that's
just excellent I mean he must go here
the only move rook b6 win here and then
maybe five and white um yeah at least in
a long time control game white is
probably winning so just too
overwhelming this play in the center
plus the porn plus the bishops early but
ok it's still tricky to planar
in the Blitz game however after Queen
here d 1 is just just trapping the Queen
he actually could have played this one
and try to continue with two minor
pieces now that's actually a bit tricky
to play I mean why this winning but hmm
no it's always this is kind of situation
where there might be night John sent and
something but okay it's it's it's
objectively and losing of course alright
thanks for watching